hope it's dangerous
it's lethal
it's a bit like the beef notorious b.i.g
used to rap about when he said beef is
when your moms ain't safe up in the
streets
beef is when i see you
guaranteed to be in icu
and
i see you
making an ass out of yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
so i was trying to think if there's
anything perhaps worse
than our pull-out from afghanistan at
first saigon pops into your head but
compared to this that now looks like a
rocket's dress rehearsal
but i did in fact find something worse
than the afghanistan cut and run it's
the president's defense of it
still a lot of pandemonium outside the
airport well there is but look
but no one's being killed right now god
forgive me for if i'm wrong about that
but no one's being killed right now
people we got a thousand somewhat 1200
out yesterday a couple thousand a day
and it's increasing
we're going to get those people out
but we've all seen the pictures we've
seen those hundreds of people packed
into a c-17 we've seen
afghans fall
four days ago five days ago
what does that even mean
it was day it was two days prior not
four of course i blame that damn racist
math
but to be fair who doesn't lose track of
time when you're in hiding constantly
nursing an ice cream headache
and as for no one's being killed right
now if joe sets the bar any lower i'll
be able to drink at it
so
it's time once again for
great job there joe
[Music]
so yeah joe sat down in an interview
with george stephanopoulos joe was
sitting george was standing on a milk
crate
so does the chaos no longer matter
because it was as he pointed out
incorrectly four or five days ago and
did he get the date deliberately wrong
considering the interview was pre-taped
does he even know where he is
we haven't seen a leader this asleep at
the wheel since ted kennedy in
chappaquiddick
[Laughter]
yeah thank you
what a strange nonsensical answer is he
really this incompetent or did he inhale
too much of that spray tan
but every time every time you think joe
biden is bad
remember what canada has
it is exactly the example of the kinds
of things you need to do to counter the
sav the she session and turn it into a
she-covery
she session
she covery
he really is full of sheet
apparently
apparently the us number one export is
no longer crude oil it's woke stupidity
except apparently in the taliban who
have up to this point taken more
questions than joe biden
and then there's this pair
it sounds like you're saying this
depends on diplomacy with the taliban
that's it that's our only option is
getting them to agree to do this
well let me
add something here helene
we got a couple
entry control points set
a north one east one and a third one at
abby gate
uh they're currently manned with
consular officers marines it's all part
of the perimeter
why is everyone acting like it's their
first day on the job
and their entire job is to protect
american citizens and yet they're more
scared of offending the political left
than those we left behind
he definitely doesn't put the milli in
military
just let that marinade
but in defense of the general none of
this was in any of robin d'angelo's
books on how to be an anti-racist
but it sounds like joe thinks we should
have gotten out a long time ago
sounds like you think we should have
gotten out a long time ago we should
have
and accept the idea that it was going to
be messy no matter what well by the way
what would be messy yeah we'd gotten out
a long time ago getting out would be
messy no matter when it occurred
maybe he's right but he could have tried
to make it a little less messy uh but it
feels like the only one who can get
major control over anything in this
country is britney spears father
joe says we anticipated all of that but
i wonder if the people clinging from the
side of the plane were made aware of
that he sounds like pee-wee herman after
flying over his handlebars declaring i
meant to do that i guess the only safe
and orderly exit the president could
muster was the one directly after his
first press conference to flee to camp
david but the real shocker of course is
that it in afghanistan took 20 years to
maintain and then fell faster than biden
in a strong wind it's guttfelt foreign
policy 101 the first thing you need to
figure out after invading a place is how
to get the hell out of it hell any bank
robber knows that the getaway car is
priority number one it's like when i go
to a biker bar first thing you do is
look for the exit and a good meth dealer
right cat
and now we have thousands of americans
there and we the most powerful nation on
earth can't get them out even france is
sending in teams to go door to door
france
the home of mimes
so this moment sucks because the whole
entire thing sucks people were making
billions off the war as pointed out by
journalist matt taibi the special
inspector general for afghan
reconstruction found 30 of 63 billion in
expenses examined was lost to fraud and
waste
if the cost of the whole war was 2
trillion the overall amount lost might
be 600 billion
so like cake at a nursing home birthday
bash everyone got a piece
everyone except the men and women who
risked their lives there some of them
died there and the ones who are lucky
enough to make it home will get maybe a
pat on the head and hear nice try maybe
next time veteran darryl owens said it
well
the u.s provided a level of stability to
afghan lives for two decades while
trying to reduce the risk of terrorism
to our country yet this week seemingly
in an instant afghanistan was given back
to the taliban with barely a whimper
so it's no surprise according to a poll
of 1.2 million vets by mission roll call
71 said this debacle was a reason for
personal sadness
but who knows maybe the taliban's
changed
do you believe the taliban have changed
no
i think let me put this way
i think they're going through
sort of an existential crisis about do
they want to be recognized
by the international communities being a
legitimate government i'm not sure i
would have predicted george nor would
you or anyone else that when we decided
to leave that they provide safe passage
for americans to get out
well that's a relief no one predicted a
safe passage from the taliban well
donald trump might disagree but if
that's the case you're saying it could
have been far worse but we got lucky
based on the kindness of murderous
strangers talk about having no plan i
put more prep into an animals or great
segment
than our leaders did to give citizens
and allies in afghanistan a safe exit
but what if the taliban has changed
i'd like to see their new look
we're getting the taliban back together
introducing taliban 2.0 it's been two
decades we've grown and we'd be heading
in the right direction this ain't your
grandfather's terror network we killed
your grandfather years ago sure we still
think women are inferior and we still
hate jews gays christians hindus
foreigners and the mets but that's
equality but now we use the right
pronouns before we kill you he died his
death see and our local offices are
always open to hear from dissenters and
we promise never to go door-to-door
looking for you we have been hearing
messages from people who are saying that
the taliban and their fighters have gone
house to house are you denying those
allegations yes i totally denied they
are not taliban so follow us on twitter
and subscribe to our youtube page they
won't censor us because we don't
criticize elections and don't forget to
smash that like button like the head of
an infidel
warning taliban 2.0 cannot guarantee the
rights or safety of lgbtq citizens women
animals or any living creature
so we got problems but it's not just the
new afghanistan it's the old biden he
may be woke but he's definitely not
awake
let's welcome tonight
if she were a restaurant all she'd be
serving is straight backs director and
former white house staffer
amanda he went to harvard and yale but
don't let that fool you he's actually
smart author of the book woke inc the
vic ramaswamy
[Applause]
she's like a glow stick bright fun and
often seen on the ground at a rave fox
news contributor cat tim
and when he walks to work janisteen
reports the weather as overcast my
massive sidekick in the nwa world
television
[Applause]
amanda what do you make of this mess
well it's kind of so dark that it's hard
to even try to have a sense of humor
about it but you've done a good job at
that that was well done thank you um i
mean the thing about it is that you know
coming from having worked at the state
department and the white house and the
former administration it's
it's it's a really dark thing to look at
because um
they are right that it's a complicated
situation and there's no good way to
leave but there's no way our
administration would have let that
happen and the thing that i think people
get confused about is why people get so
angry and frequently
uh point to the woke-ism the obsession
with like millie and these guys
certainly our current state department
with uh wokism overdoing their job is
because
moments like this are why we need them
to be good at their basic job right
their most basic fundamental job is to
get americans out of harm's way and to
not uh
conduct ourselves in a way that is this
embarrassing on the world stage and this
and projects this much weakness it's
actually a national security issue and
it's um
so that's what's really frustrating i
think that's gotten lost is that a lot
of times it's easy to sort of um
you know joke about it like yeah they're
they're not looking at
they don't have the instructions on how
to get out of afghanistan in the white
fragility book which is true but the the
frustrating thing is you're like you
know add your little programs add your
your eons of ngos doing uh female bead
making entrepreneurship programs after
you figure out the basics you know
that's a good point i've only had
somebody who wrote a book about wokism
on this on the set so cat rebecca
this is why like when people dismissed
that that this wokism isn't a big deal
it is a big deal because it replaces
something it totally does it replaces
american fortitude i think there's
exactly one way that joe biden could
have prevented the situation from
happening it is issuing a threat to the
taliban a credible threat that we will
completely annihilate you if you renege
on your agreements and mess around with
our exit from afghanistan and if you can
do that critically they wouldn't have
messed around they would not have gone
for kabul they might have done some
small stuff around the edges in the
tribal warlord area they would not have
gone for kabul but joe biden couldn't do
it you want to know why because he is
obsessed with self-criticism of the
united states and even the taliban knows
that he thinks he doesn't have the moral
standing to back up that threat so
that's why they went for it and i think
that's the way that wokism destructs
america on the global stage is it
reduces our moral standing to use
extraordinary force precisely when we
need it most so i think that's part of
it i also just think it was incompetent
i mean if you're joe biden why wouldn't
you go in the winter okay you know we
have a thing called a football season in
america yeah the taliban they have this
thing i'm not even kidding yeah fighting
season yes it is summer yeah so guess
what in winter it's cold they have snow
that might have been a good time to go
but instead he wants the symbolism of
doing it before 9 11 now we're gonna
have the symbolism of the taliban flag
flying on top of the u.s embassy on the
20th anniversary of 9 11 when those
planes hit those towers i never thought
i'd see the day and here we are yeah
it's true it's true it's it it was all
to bake it before a date and then when
you choose a date and that you tell
everybody that's what's happening and
you do it when they fight it's a it's a
bit strange that they have a fighting
season but
well we all kind of have a fight you see
that's true
mine's around being honest yeah it's
literally two or three days a week when
i'm home it's like
oh yeah oh
jojo
get it it's
it's hard to admit when you're wrong but
uh
what are we doing
we we need to respect our boots but we
gotta get rid of the suits like if there
was anybody who's thinking about not
voting this year
if this is not what we've seen to get
you going there should be record number
of
votes going on in the senate and the
house is up because
how is any administration i mean
i'm not a rocket scientist but the first
thing i would have done was i would have
killed their social media platform you
realize the taliban is not only pushing
their propaganda they're also using it
to find where people are hiding to that
flag on the building went everywhere
they're getting world recognition
but yet if you say a bad thing about
somebody or if you were in the fifth
grade and said the wrong thing you're
canceled or whatever but here's a
platform where people are actually dying
right we're seeing it on the streets
we're getting text messages and messages
from all around the world hearing about
people being shot at and kept away from
airports and we're seeing all these
horrible things and all we've gotten so
far is a scathing email right that was
sent
we sent a scathing email not working
great point
how about you know just say you know
what i get it you're woke maybe just
send the video
of the bomb that president trump dropped
yeah you know i'm saying maybe send that
or say you know he's a phone call away
you know whatever because there was a
time you didn't like what he said on
twitter so he took him off but his
foreign policy
every one of those countries
fought before they stepped yeah now
they're just like our borders it's open
season and they're literally posting
while they do it that's how arrogant and
confident they are based on this
spineless administration yeah they need
to send the solomonie picture yeah send
the picture of what they did to salt
what we did to solomonia and clean all
that up yeah you know cat i what i miss
is you know listening or reading any of
chrissy teigen's tweets about the
taliban i yeah i think i think there's a
big there's a big empty space i think
that she might have been able to solve
this i think so too her withering wit
yeah absolutely i for one was very
shocked to hear biden say that he
doesn't think that the taliban is
killing people because i've seen the
videos and not a mask in sight yeah
so and like they're not you know they're
also not using their platform to
encourage vaccinations that is true so
murderers all on their own i mean look
it's it's so gross to watch so many of
these things on so many levels and not
least of all that news conference with
the generals those top military guys
complaining about erroneous reporting
right after the years of
that they fed us about this war and
putting people in harm's way based on
lies
a river shut up um only one from cat
today okay yeah you get two more for the
rest of the show so so parsley doesn't
have any more plans well okay well then
depends on where it goes okay all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else